a Dharma is when somebody is living
their purpose
so each of us have a nature and if we're
able to tap into that nature fully
understand it and then use it in the
highest capacity possible for that
nature that's Dharma and in Dharma it's
a different it's literally
less Cosmic laws
govern Dharma then the lower levels so
you have let's say Baseline
Consciousness is one that in mysticism
is called somnibalistic but let's just
call it unconsciousness
so if the Baseline is unconsciousness
there's more Cosmic laws to govern them
so you could look at it like a hypnotic
State man is under stronger forces of
sleep he has less free will
so there's a stronger pull a gravity
towards sleep
the more a person starts to awaken
the more they hopefully are using that
Awakening to go wait a second I can
access more of my free will
the more free will they access they're
not changing their nature they're
understanding their nature and
understanding their nature plus
Awakening equals accessing their dharmic
path their purpose their you know what
um Campbell called Bliss
hmm
so so that realm is a different realm
than What's called the general law or
what I was talking about uncon
unconsciousness
and so
so that's why you're having those
experiences and then when people are are
in their Dharma
they may possibly think that everyone
might be in their Dharma and so a large
part of my purpose is I really would
like to help harness people's
discernment because that's what's going
to allow them to access more free will
create more sovereignty and maybe they
might hop on their dharmic timeline
explain how people can do that more if
somebody's like yeah I want to do that
what do they do first and foremost it
really depends on like I don't like
being linear at all but it depends on
how much capacity for truth a person can
have
because there are certain things that
are subjective and then there's certain
things that are not subjective at all
and so just like how you were saying
earlier like is this predetermined that
it's both it's you get random variables
called chaos and then you get ordered
which was predetermined and then you put
them in a little bag like two cats and
you watch them fight and see what
happens
and so there is always that Randomness
that comes out of that construction so
there's predestined mixed with what are
you going to do next
and so between those two is how we live
our life and so how a person can harness
enough of their free will to enter their
Dharma is by first understanding
that those two are in harmony with one
another
and
we could look at it as the subjective
and the objective having a higher
capacity for the objective meaning the
objective truth of the world is going to
allow a person to locate themselves in
like what's actually reality in this you
know because I know that there's a lot
of different ways that can be
interpreted like like what do you mean
by this reality but the consensus
reality
okay so understanding having a larger
capacity for truth will allow a person
to now go oh wait a second maybe that
wasn't my purpose maybe this is my
purpose so do you see how if we're not
located in truth we might think our
purpose is like oh man I'm supposed to
go
be an actor and acting school I got
nothing against acting I wanted to be an
actor that's why I'm using this as an
example
but if we're not located fully in truth
maybe that's not our purpose maybe
that's not our joy maybe that's and that
could be someone's and that could
totally be someone's Dharma one person's
Dharma might be acting in another
person's Dharma might not be acting at
all but a being won't know how to locate
themselves and what their actual dharmas
if they're not having a larger capacity
for truth does that make sense huh well
yes yes it does and you know as soon as
you said the word truth I
it's something that I seek very deeply
like I no matter what the pain I want to
know the truth because I know that it's
eventual
um I know that it will put me on my more
accurate path I know it will lead to
more joy more peace more more Evolution
more growth
um I think that's why I say yes to plant
medicine I say yes to it's just I'm I'm
ready for the truth I want to know it no
matter what it's probably why I move
fast in a lot of situations because it's
like let's just cut to the chase here
um so I think it's worth like spending a
minute unpacking what truth is
truth is objective reality we have
subjective reality and objective reality
they're not in Conflict now I've come
from as we talked about earlier
mysticism and in some sectors of
mysticism
they worship objectivity
to the point where I had to kind of like
heal an accident aversion that I had to
subjectivity just because of how much
dominant objectivity is
so objectivity is considered truth
now there's subjective truths people
have and that's their personal
experience and then there's objective
truth meaning that
what out of all the potential available
energies there was one thing that
actually manifested
all the other ones we could call
subjective potential available
but the thing that became what is
the thing out of all of those variants
that went no but it could be something
simple like I opened a refrigerator door
I closed it that is the truth of that
action
if now somebody comes along and says she
opened the refrigerator door she put
food in there and then she closed it
that's not the truth
that's not what happened that's not what
is
so objectivity broken down to something
so simple as that like refrigerator
example is
what is what happened in the past and
what hap is happening now
that's truth
how about an example of there's a car
accident
there's four Witnesses
they all give their report after seeing
the accident of what happened and all
four have slightly different stories
like I'm very curious about whether
about objective realities and whether or
not they exist because we all have our
own personal lens of how we see things
so I'm really curious what really
creates an objective reality just like
you walking across the river you're not
the same and the river's not the same
you can't you can't do it twice the same
way you're not the same person it's not
the same experience so really what
creates an objective reality other than
our perception
who's percepting
so let's use your example of the
accident where there were four people
the objective
Viewpoint would be
the camera that was in the air
that was had it below the Observer the
oversoul the higher self yes yes the
yeah that would be the objective one and
that's not to say that that's battling
people's subcl people's you know
subjective reality
one of those people might have had a
very accurate perception more than the
other three people who were who were
reported
but that person let's call it the one
out of the four who had the most
accurate account could have been let's
now use this as a metaphor for
spirituality the one that was most in
alignment with the oversoul yeah right
less traumas less less
um less fractioning of their being
because of things that had happened that
made them see a situation different
because of too much karma too much too
many traumas that would distort
the truth which is the oversoul higher
self objective reality so it almost gets
back to a little bit of like our the
very beginning when it's like I'm trying
to see if their uh what their projecting
matches their frequency it's like how
much truth is here like can you be can
you hold
how how much how much [ __ ] do you
have
how's my coffee go I'm too magical for
your [ __ ] how much how much [ __ ]
is in the way of you being able to see
more of that objective reality truth
that the oversoul or higher self is
seeing in that way
exactly so in this case scenario it
would be the person who was closest to
the thing
so not all of the even their reporting
could have been equal
so yeah so so it's subjective reality I
do not want to negate that at all
because I came very much from schools of
complete negation of anything emotional
and subjective
so the subjectivity of our own personal
experiences
are contributing to the consensus
reality
so they're not opposing forces at least
I don't perceive them as them I view it
as Harmony and I view it at a higher
level as the masculine and The Feminine
energies in a form of symbiosis whereas
with here it gets translated into a lot
of like conflict sure because it's
essentially the way I guess I'm seeing
it is that the oversoul it's like it's
you it's still you so it's just seeing
things from a different perspective
which I totally want to ask about
Dimension so don't let me forget
um but it's it's working with you and in
this guided process through this Human
Experience it's it's sort of right there
and I feel like part of my work that
I've been doing more deeply is getting
more in touch with that intuitive side
of me the the psychic intuitive
um and you know just part of me that is
like the quiet voice underneath that is
leading you through your life that most
of the time and for most people never
know is there
you're doing it
I'm trying to do it
um okay let's talk about Dimensions I
get very fascinated with this and and
you know can you explain them and what
they are and how they play into our
reality and of course you know here we
are trying to shift into a new reality
of new Earth 5D so like what's what's
happening
yeah so the fifth dimensional
Consciousness is what needs to be
embodied first and for those of you that
are wondering what happened to 4D we're
in 40. we're already in 40 which is
the fourth dimension is one that well in
layman's terms it's mathematical every
time I talk about the fourth dimension
people go like it's math and stuff it's
like I know but it's just sexier to call
it the Matrix but the Matrix is
mathematical reconfigurations and we're
projected into that so the third and the
fourth you can kind of just look like
that could even be like a really cool
Tool song like the third and the fourth
like that's just like the third and the
fourth are like the same so The Fifth
Dimension is a fifth dimensional
consciousness of
Oneness that enlightened State I was
talking about and now not the gnarly
fragmented parts of that but the overall
symbiosis of us being the Creator and
the created not in a Creator way where
we're putting ourselves you know um
above Spirit
um there's this even this dichotomy
going on in Consciousness in in the
spiritual Community where I see people
fighting a lot over like
we're the Creator or no were they
created and it's like bro like like I
calm down like like when you're in fifth
dimensional Consciousness you're in
unity Consciousness so you don't have
the ego of going like
you don't have the subservient ego of
I'm below and you don't have the you
know um
the over the the superior ego of like I
am I meant I'm everything so it because
it's Unity Consciousness and so it's the
integrated ego and the integrated ego
understands that they're the ambassador
of source
and so that fifth dimensional
Consciousness understands inherently
just a part of that Consciousness is to
be out of Separation Consciousness and
into Unity Consciousness because of that
it's heart centered because how could
you be in unity
and still inflict pain yeah because it's
you
exactly does that person that you are
inflicting pain on is you you couldn't
do it if you like this clip and you want
to hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen
[Music]